[Musique]
la migration vers la métropole était
allé d'une conséquence de la
départementalisation puisque la
dépendent mentalisation s'est traduite
par une amélioration des conditions
sanitaires de la population donc la
population a augmenté considérablement
et il y avait des problèmes de débouchés
de formation et il y avait aussi
beaucoup de misère puisque les lois
sociales n'étaient pas encore mises en
oeuvre donc beaucoup de gens étaient
amenés à partir en france métropolitaine
pourra trouver une formation et un
emploi ça a été le cas du bumidom
c'était une question qui était tellement
importante et je me souviens bien quand
j'étais beaucoup plus jeune c'était
tellement important que j'en ai fait
l'objet de ma de ma maîtrise quand
j'étais étudiant à aix en provence en
géographie après ma licence
et depuis durant toute ma vie
professionnelle je me suis toujours
occupé de cette migration en faisant un
livre avec monsieur alain lorraine sur
les réunionnais en métropole il y a un
peu plus de vingt ans intitulé 175000
réunionnais en métropole une communauté
invisible en étant membre de la
commission nationale d'études chez les
enfants de la creuse
créé par le gouvernement il ya quatre
ans donc tout ça pour dire que tout au
long de ma vie j'ai traité de ce type de
sujet ce sont des sujets d'ailleurs que
j'ai vu évoluer puisque autrefois
c'était le but me d'hommes les
empaqueter avec peu de formations pas
beaucoup de garanties trouver un avenir
en france métropolitaine mais maintenant
la migration s'est beaucoup diversifiée
et c'est le département qui en a qui a
pris en charge la mobilité pour un
emploi par le biais d'une arme du comité
national d'action et d'accueil des
réunionnais en métropole et l'état
continue à accompagner la migration par
le biais de ladom et notamment pour des
gens qui veulent chasser une formation
et puis le la région depuis 2004
également organisé une formation des
réunionnais vers le québec est
vingt ans les réunionnais sont passés de
quelques centaines au québec et
maintenant il y à plus de 2000 créant
des neiges au québec donc le la
migration fait partie du vécu des
réunionnais et tout le monde ici dans
aussi bien dans la salle que dans la
ville réunionnaise a toujours un parent
un ami une connaissance installés en
france métropolitaine
vous aviez aussi ici en france
métropolitaine mais c'est des photos
d'époque donc des années 1960 des jeunes
réunionnais qui étaient installés en
métropole par le biais du bumidom qui
parfois été assez nombreux par par
sambre et puis elle ces réunionnais
s'étaient aussi organisés pour défendre
des intérêts et c'étaient les jeunes qui
partent et se faire un avenir là bas
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on avait au
départ crée le cnam avec michel debré
c'était pour que les réunionnais
puissent se retrouver dans des foyers
bon ces foyers vais aussi une mission
c'est de ne pas délaisser aller dans la
nature sans aucun port d'attache mais
les réunionnais finissait toujours par
se retrouver soi sur le travail parce
qu'ils étaient concentrées sur dans les
hôpitaux dans les postes et
télécommunications dont nous avions
organisé les assises de des réunionnais
en france métropolitaine et de ces
assises de ces travaux de ces échanges
est sorti un ouvrage que l'on ait
intitulé 175000 réunionnais en france
métropolitaine une communauté invisible
parce que les réunionnais en france
métropolitaine sont tellement divers au
niveau des ethnies au niveau de la
couleur de la peau qu'on les prenait
pour tout autre chose que des
réunionnais ceux qui étaient blancs
étaient pris pour des oreilles ce qui
était un peu bronzé comme moi été pris
par des livres pour des libanais ou des
maghrébins ceux qui étaient noirs et
puis par des africains
donc c'est pour ça qu'on dit que c'était
une communauté invisible mais c'était
une communauté qui existaient bel et
bien puisque
on se retrouvait donc très souvent
[Musique]